personas bajadas y comercios no
esenciales cerrados las escenas del
confinamiento de marzo y abril vuelven a
repetirse en francia aunque parece que
con más gente por las calles que en la
pasada primavera
el encierro parece diferente el primero
porque en abril no había tanta gente en
las calles parece diferente por el
momento no veo mucha diferencia con otro
día salvo que los cafés están cerrados
las nuevas restricciones afectan sobre
todo a bares y restaurantes ya que los
colegios y universidades seguirán
abiertos al igual que los servicios
esenciales
unas medidas a las que muchos ciudadanos
se resignan a wii no no creo que no
tenemos otra opción en algún momento
tenemos que salir de esto así que si no
fuimos disciplinados antes tendremos que
ser disciplinados ahora tenemos que
hacerlo de manera inteligente las
salidas tendrán que estar justificadas
para ir al trabajo y aunque los
servicios públicos y de culto
permanecerán abiertos se necesita un
permiso para prácticamente todo algo que
algunos no terminan de aceptar
modificado tengo 82 años estamos
confinados no tenemos derecho a movernos
necesitamos un formulario de permisos
son siempre los mismos papeles y es
inútil es la segunda ola de coronavirus
ha golpeado a francia con dureza
registrándose varios récords diarios de
casos en las últimas semanas algo que ha
hecho que el país sea el segundo en
europa junto con irlanda en volverse a
confinar